now to the coronavirus hospitalizations
all across the country have hit an
all-time
high yesterday more than 144 thousand
infections and nearly 1900 deaths deaths
were reported that's the highest since
may health officials worry the system
cannot handle a prolonged
spike in cases we're still able to
handle any patient that comes our way
but it's it's certainly to the point of
making us wonder what comes next
maryland is reimposing restrictions
in-person gatherings they are limited to
25 people
and in new york city governor andrew
cuomo is bringing back restrictions on
gyms
bars and restaurants southern nevada
hospitals though say they can't handle
the amount of coronavirus patients they
have
still staff are preparing for a second
surge right now 82 percent of hospital
beds in southern nevada are occupied
15 percent are coveted 19 patients
intensive care units are 66 percent
occupied with nearly 35 percent coveted
positive umc ceo mason van gaaling says
the increase in cases
is serious we're not at our peaks that
where we saw
uh in april and then july at the july
4th weekend
so we're just trying to avoid that and
be get really ahead of this
so but we're in good shape but that can
quickly change
van howling says much of this surge is
because people just aren't wearing masks
or washing their hands
and he thinks the positivity rate
getting it under control in two weeks is
only attainable if everyone does their
part
we're just trying to get ahead of that
especially for our economy here in
southern nevada we want to make sure we
kept
keep open we've done such great work
over the last three to four months
but unfortunately that's being unwound
and we're going backwards
where we want to keep pushing forwards
we are just two days now into governor
steve sissellac's recent
stay at home request the governor asking
everyone to only go out when necessary
limit outside exposure avoid large and
small gatherings and work from home as
much as possible
if you have to be in an office wear a
mask the governor says if numbers do not
improve the next two weeks
he will impose stricter guidelines